i know you're famous for all these
pranks which i think some of them are
are unbelievably
evil genius the rottenest one we did was
i started
a campaign for matt damon like if you
live in hollywood there's
two entertainment papers you know
variety in the hollywood reporter at the
time and
you'd see during the oscar campaign
you'd see you know for your
consideration for best actor
you know and they'd put up every page is
a full
picture of the actors so i took out ads
with matt damon remember he wore this
green speedo and talented mr ripley
took that picture of him and just
literally very seriously he said you
know for your consideration
sexiest man alive and we just kept
pummeling it
for i don't know two years and they
finally gave it to him
i did one to brad that was really brutal
because he just
destroyed me when we were shooting
ocean's 12 he was in como
staying with us and he in italian had a
posters put up all around town saying
that george clooney only wants to be
called danny ocean and don't look him in
the all in italian which i couldn't read
and it got in the papers ildivo and i
was the total jerk
but then the worst one was jimmy kimmel
gave me brad pitt stationery yeah
and so i started sending letters to
actors from brad pitt
you know how you get stuff sent in the
mail that's just you know tons of fan
mail in there
and there's one this voice coach sent me
this giant
folder of like 60 cds in it
and he was a voice coach and he's like
you know a voice for the stage and
screen
and it's like gaelic accent and you know
all it's just ridiculous you know
right and so meryl streep was about to
play a margaret thatcher
like she's the greatest actress of all
time you know right i sent it to her
this package of 60 cds of accents
for the stage and screen and they said
from brad with a card from brad and said
dear meryl i hear you're going to play
the iron lady this guy helped me with my
accent in troy
i heard a story my wife told me the
story that you told my wife
this so george had a friend that got a
kitten
yeah that's richard okay tell what you
did i was living
with him i'd broken up with someone i
was living in his apartment a
one-bedroom apartment
i was sleeping on the couch and he was
working he was doing the carol burnett
show then
and uh and he was going to work every
day and i had nothing to do as an
unemployed actor
right he had this little kitten right
next to the toilet in there
was a cat box you know and it was always
you know filled with cat [ __ ] because
you never cleaned it out and i'm always
scooping it up and
you know right you know cleaning it out
and you know and then i i was sitting
there watching jeopardy when he comes
home
and he's like he goes in the bathroom he
comes out and he goes
my my little kitten has not taken a [ __ ]
and i think three days and i don't say
anything
i don't know why i don't tell him that
i've scooped all the [ __ ] up
and you know the cat doesn't go out it
stays in this apartment right
and so you know the next day he goes to
work i scoop up the cat [ __ ] he comes in
he's like
i don't understand it it doesn't make
sense right and he keeps doing that for
days and i don't know why i'm doing it i
just think it's funny
and then i'm in there about to scoop it
up the next round
and then the the light just finally
dawns on me
and i take a giant [ __ ] in the cat box
right and i wait for richard to come
home
and i'm sitting there watching jeopardy
i don't say a word
and richard goes into the bathroom and
he's in there for a second and i hear
oh my god oh my god kenny
you can't believe this and you know the
cat's this big